[Music]
one division wait until you see this
show it's unlike anything we've done
before our writer Jack Schaeffer and our
director Matt Jackman this is gonna be
something a series that Marvel fans have
never seen before it is half classic
sitcom and half full MCU spectacular
it's Lauren
so much of the fun and watching the show
for fans will be the unexpected
discovery of where and when and the MCU
this series takes place and how it all
fits into that larger picture
it is extremely cool in large part
because Lizzie Olsen Paul Bettany are
starring in it two of the most iconic
Avengers Wanda Maximoff in division
we're gonna have a lot of fun it's gonna
get weird we're gonna go deep we're
gonna have lots of surprises and we're
gonna finally understand Wanda Maximoff
as the Scarlet Witch it's so funny and
it's just ends up being this huge epic
it's the the writing so extraordinary
and thank you very much joining the cast
reprising her role as Darcy Lewis is kat
dennings that was in our first two four
films and is remarkable to have you in
this as well so good to see you
lieutenant trouble Akira Akbar played
her wonderfully in Captain Marvel's
little girl on Wanda vision as an adult
meet your new Monica Rambeau Tiana Paris
[Applause]
reprising his role as agent Jimmy woo
from ant-man the wasp Randall Park
is my great honor to reveal the nosy
neighbor of one division the amazing
Catherine hi thank you for coming the
cast and the filmmakers are on division
welcome back everyone it's Charlie so
because Disney Plus launched Marvel
released all these big Marvel phase four
teasers and trailers idios so this will
be about all the Scarlet Witch and
vision one division stuff that they're
filming right now and then the Doctor
Strange two points of crossover we're
doing that big infinity saga box set
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and let me know what
your most hyped up about for the Wan
division series I know there's a whole
bunch of questions about Scarlet Witch
because technically she's a mutant in
the comics and now that they have the
x-men again are they gonna use this
series to set up the concept of mutants
in the MCU so I'll address that during
the video but we'll just break this all
down top-five style starting with number
5 the new footage and the new Easter
eggs that they reveal during this so if
you look in the background especially
when this producer is talking about the
series you can see all the comic book
panels that are inspiring the story in
the moments that they're gonna be doing
it reads like a blueprint of all the WTF
moments that they're incorporating into
the story a lot of you will be psyched
up to see that they have a whole bunch
of different versions of pictures of
them having children from that original
vision in Scarlet Witch comic book
series that's almost half the wall them
having those children's so I'll talk
about her children from the comics in a
second Wiccan and speed because that
gets into future MCU Disney Plus Young
Avengers stuff but they're also comic
book panels from scarlet witch's House
of M no more mutants iconic moment where
she alters reality getting rid of a vast
majority of all mutants on the planet
there's some panels of Mephisto mixed in
here too which seem like they're
actually from spider-man's one more day
but Mephisto was responsible for her
children she thought she had with vision
which later they retcon because the
Marvel editor after that title was
published really really hated what the
people did with that vision and Scarlet
Witch miniseries so he wanted to wreak
on the fact that they had children
together so the new back story after the
retcon was that Mephisto was just
messing with her and the children were
just two shards of his soul like
Horcruxes then they're a couple more
recent comic book panels back here with
her using her chaos magic which she's
done many times in the comics using her
biggest WTF moments from the comics
involve her warping realities somehow on
some large scale with her chaos magic
all explained what a lot of these mean
in terms of the context of the story in
a second but then number four there's
the high quality d23 preview
them in that living room so we've seen
this picture before but this is just
colored properly notice how different it
looks they're sitting in that 1950s
looking Dick Van Dyke Show living room
with only the portion covered by the
light from the TV being in color the
rest of the room being in black and
white so that tells you all you need to
know about how she brings this into
reality it implies that Scarlet Witch
will be creating a reality for herself
the way that she can alter reality in
the comics using chaos magic and those
powers will be how they explain how her
children Wiccan and speed can exist in
the MCU if they want to keep them around
after the series which it sounds like
they might also notice the way that they
handle these transitions so they're
static during the transitions like
static from a TV as if you're changing
channels to different stations changing
to different realities like scarlet
which can create realities when they
transition to the scene of them in that
Dick Van Dyke reality sitting in front
of the TV the frame actually opens as if
you're turning the TV on for the first
time then you see a bunch of background
static that they added on top of the
flashbacks to Avengers age of Ultron in
her past implying that there are gonna
be some cracks in reality things just
won't be completely a hundred percent
that's really where things start to spin
out of control which I'll talk about in
a second because they did kind of say
how they're plotting the season out and
how it's gonna spin up into Doctor
Strange to number three the overall
story that they've told us about so far
so they said the first half of the
series will be this weird 1950s sitcom
like a meta Dick Van Dyke Show if you've
never watched the Dick Van Dyke Show
the reason why they're using that within
the universe of that show dick Van
Dyke's character was a writer on a
Hollywood TV show it's just that in the
context of the Scarlet Witch and vision
wand division series Wanda is going to
be that Dick Van Dyke character the
person who's quote-unquote riding the
show the show about the person that's
writing a show for herself her own new
reality they also said that some of
those parts of the episodes might be
filmed in front of a live studio
audience just to give that sort of Dick
Van Dyke 1950s ambiance because a lot of
those TV shows back during that period
were filmed in front of a live studio
audience --is then the second half is
going to be this giant huge crazy Marvel
action movie more likely he was seen in
one of the Avengers films so that's
where it sounds like
he just completely goes batshit crazy
there are also rumors that they're going
to involve the Agatha Hartness character
who is the person in the comics that
mentored Scarlet Witch and helped her
learn how to use her chaos magic for the
first time and then became a villain for
her so we'll talk about her in a second
too because she is definitely not the
main villain of Doctor Strange too and
they'll sort of set up the villain of
Doctor Strange too at the end of The
Scarlet Witch envisioned one division
series because think about it this way
if she's not in control of her chaos
magic and she's trying to cobble
together a reality for herself
think about how her actions might alter
our reality and what is dr. Strange's
main job
he tells Iron Man to his face I protect
your reality douchebag but number two
new characters that they've confirmed
they introduced during that big panel
there Jimmy woo FBI agent still working
on close-up magic after ant-man in the
wasp because they're borrowing some of
the story from Tom King's vision run
where vision kind of did a version of
this for himself in Washington DC
he was the avengers liaison with the US
government but because the wan division
series is centered around the Scarlet
Witch character is probably Thunderbolt
Ross in the US government trying to keep
tabs on her because she's one of the
most powerful people on the planet of
course Thunderbolt Ross would want some
eyeballs on her then there's the adult
version of Monica Rambeau
who might also be working for
Thunderbolt Ross or the military
following in her mother's footsteps from
the Captain Marvel movie based on what
Darcy was doing during the course of
thor ragnarok and they were
experimenting with portals going to
other worlds I imagine that has
something to do with the multiverse plot
but she's basically the scientist
amongst that group then the Kathryn Hahn
character I think might wind up playing
Agatha Harkness because she's the only
person that they don't list a name for
on IMDB and they called her the
quote/unquote nosy neighbor if you don't
recognize her or her voice she actually
played the female Doctor Octopus during
spider-man into the spider verse so
she's no stranger to comic book movies
and she has a very powerful presence and
does a lot of drama so I feel like she
would be a really good foil for Scarlet
Witch someone who can't help her but
also be something of an antagonist so
number one basic outline here is Scarlet
Witch learning about her Chaos magic
reality-warping and through that tearing
the fabric of the multiverse and reality
itself apart at the seams that seems
like it would be where dr. stray
gets involved in why he would need a
scarlet witch's help during his movie
because he's the most powerful sorcerer
in the universe according to the Russos
as of Avengers infinity war she would
only be useful to him if she were just
as powerful if not more powerful or had
abilities that he couldn't replicate yet
it sounds like they're gonna do a little
bit of house of em that really just gets
into reality warping powers and bringing
her children back into existence then
maybe some sort of battle with Agatha
Harkness before you get into big Doctor
Strange to stuff but everybody let me
know in the comments if there's any
Easter eggs you spotted during all this
footage that I didn't mention in the
video and what are you most excited
about leave all your video requests in
the comments below there's a bunch of
Marvel stuff coming up the Black Widow
trailer is probably gonna drop in a
couple weeks too so everybody click here
for my brand-new Avengers v Holt video
and click here for my brand-new Rick and
Morty season 4 episode 2 video thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]